Seamos honestos un año después de la irrupción
de la COVID-19, todos nos hemos convertido
- aunque solo sea un poquito - en expertos
en pandemias.
A ver, ¿Quién se atreve a decirme que nunca
ha discutido sobre esta o aquella vacuna?¿Sobre
las PRC, los Test de antígenos o el origen
del virus? Me apuesto que ninguno.
Sin embargo, aunque nos parezca que ya nos
sabemos el nombre y apellido de todas las
vacunas habidas y por haber, estoy seguro
de que en esta ocasión vais a descubrir algo
nuevo.
Decidme: ¿habéis oído hablar alguna vez
de la vacuna uzbeko-china? Me la juego a que
no.
Amigos, hablamos de una vacuna que se ha registrado
en Uzbekistán bajo el nombre ZF-UZ-VAC2001.
[Como para recordarlo].
Pero no os preocupéis, porque hoy no nos
vamos a meter en bioquímica. Lo que me interesa
es que nos fijemos en esa curiosa relación:
China y Uzbekistán:
¿Por qué decidieron producir juntos esta
vacuna? ¿Qué es exactamente lo que une a
estos dos países?
En este vídeo tenemos mucho de qué hablar.
Y no solo lo haremos de Uzbekistán. Queridos
amigos, amigas, en el mapamundi hay una región
en la que todos decidieron ponerle a sus países
el mismo sufijo.
Hablamos de Kazajistán, Uzbekistán, Kirguistán,
Tayikistán y Turkmenistán o, en otras palabras,
Asia Central.
Esta región estuvo en el punto de mira de
las grandes potencias desde el siglo XIX.
Y hoy la situación no ha cambiado mucho.
La competición por la influencia se disputa
hoy entre Rusia, Estados Unidos, Turquía,
India, Pakistán y, por supuesto, China.
Pekín lleva años invirtiendo en los istanes:
construye infraestructuras, envía a su mano
de obra y controla porcentajes altísimos
de la deuda externa de estos países. Y eso
es precisamente lo que vamos a ver: ¿qué
está haciendo China en Asia Central? ¿Quién
sale ganando? ¿Se está acaso convirtiéndose
esta región del mundo en el nuevo campo de
expansión del recobrado Imperio Chino?
¡Arranquemos!
(UN MATRIMONIO MARGONÁTICO)
Como quizás ya hayas sospechado, en este
vídeo vamos a hablar mucho de dinero.
Y es que aquí encontramos una de las fronteras
más desiguales del mundo.
Por ejemplo, a ninguno os sorprenderá si
os digo que el PIB de China es 50 veces mayor
que el de todos los países de Asia Central
juntos.
Vamos, que comparar a China con, por ejemplo,
Tayikistán, es como hablar de David y Goliat.
Claro que en este caso, David y Goliat no
se pelean, sino que comercian.
Lo que no resulta extraño. Al fin y al cabo,
hablamos de países vecinos y lo raro sería
que no tuvieran ninguna relación comercial.
Pero, lo cierto es que China es también uno
de los principales inversores y acreedores
de Asia Central. Y de todos, lo que más le
interesa es el sector energético.
(Una empresa china construirá una planta
hidroeléctrica en Kazajistán)
(Eximbank chino asigna un préstamo a un banco
uzbeko para modernizar centrales hidroeléctricas.)
Y eso no es todo. Lo veremos luego, pero ya
os adelanto que varias rutas de la Nueva Ruta
de la Seda pasan precisamente por Asia Central.
Por eso, Pekín también está construyendo
y financiando las infraestructuras de transporte,
como carreteras y ferrocarriles, que necesita
para garantizar el tránsito de sus productos.
Eso sí, recordad que hablamos de países
entre poco y nada democráticos, en los que
gobierna simple y llanamente con un poder
absoluto: la corrupción.
Así que, muchas veces, el dinero se evapora
en las propias estadísticas oficiales.
Por eso las inversiones extranjeras son una
apuesta arriesgada, e incluso China ya se
ha quemado más de una vez. Así que últimamente
se dedica a proyectos más pequeños: algunas
fábricas y plantas de cemento o minas de
oro, cobre, zinc y otros recursos naturales.
(Por otro lado, Pekín también está financiando
en estos países la construcción de escuelas
y facultades en las que se estudia chino,
está abriendo Institutos Confucio por toda
la región e incluso tiene en marcha un montón
de programas de becas, para que los estudiantes
centroasiáticos puedan hacer intercambios
académicos en China.
Todo un ejemplo de expansión del poder blando.
La nueva realidad de la influencia china que
en Occidente aún desconocemos pero que cada
vez tiene más peso.)
En total, en los últimos quince años China
ha destinado 54 mil millones de dólares a
las inversiones y la construcción en Asia
Central. Es decir, más o menos lo mismo que
todo el PIB de Uzbekistán.
Pero, amigos, puede que a estas alturas estáis
pensando que la relación de Asia Central
con China solo está marcada por el dinero.
Pues lo cierto es que tienen algo más en
común: su pasión por la tecnología y el
control.
Decidme, ¿qué nombre le daríais a un proyecto
que consiste en la vigilancia constante y
el reconocimiento facial? Pues, al mejor estilo
orweilliano, se llama “ciudades seguras”.
Y no sé si os gusta la idea, pero os puedo
decir a quién le encanta:
Tayikistán y Uzbekistán están desarrollando
ya sus programas de “ciudades seguras”
de la mano de Huawei. Por supuesto, en el
concepto de seguridad se tiene sobre en cuenta
la seguridad de los jerifaltes que ocupan
el poder.
Y, siguiendo con Tayikistán, no podemos olvidarnos
de un aspecto más en sus relaciones con China.
Hablamos de la presencia militar:
(Un recién llegado silencioso en las montañas
de Asia Central: las tropas chinas)
Ya sabéis que China tiene bases militares
en Yibuti y en el mar del Sur de China. Pero
la de Tayikistán es su primera aparición
en Asia Central, y tiene que ver con la seguridad
en la frontera afgana. Fijaos en este mapa
Estáis viendo la triple frontera entre China,
Tayikistán y Afganistán, en el corredor
de Wakhan.
La primera base militar china en Asia Central
está situada en el territorio tayiko muy
cerca de este punto.
Puede que no os parezca algo tan importante,
pero para China es todo un hito y un salto
de gigante. Hasta ahora sus relaciones con
la región se limitaban a la parte económica.
Pero el peso de China está creciendo y ahora
quiere alcanzar un nuevo rol.
Incluso, durante los últimos meses Pekín
no ha dejado escapar la oportunidad de afianzar
su influencia en Asia Central con un nuevo
tipo de diplomacia: la de las vacunas.
Si recordáis, empezamos este vídeo hablando
de la vacuna uzbeko-china, desarrollada por
la biofarmacéutica china Anhui Zhifei Longcom
(Anui Chufei Loncom y por la Academia China
de las Ciencias.
Y me diréis: “si las dos instituciones
son chinas, ¿qué pinta ahí Uzbekistán?”.
Pues aquí empieza lo interesante. Uzbekistán
fue uno de los países que participó en los
ensayos de esta vacuna. También lo han hecho,
por ejemplo, Ecuador y Paquistán. Pero en
febrero de 2021 ocurría esto:
(La empresa china reconoció a Uzbekistán
como coautor en el desarrollo de la vacuna
ZF-2001)
Uzbekistán se convertía oficialmente en
el coautor de la vacuna, gracias, cito, “a
su contribución y esfuerzo”. No sabemos
si es que Pakistán y Ecuador no se habían
esforzado lo suficiente, pero lo cierto es
que la siguiente noticia tardó menos de dos
semanas en ver la luz:
(Uzbekistán aprueba la vacuna para la COVID-19
desarrollada por China)
Fue el primer país de Asia Central en hacerlo,
y de esta forma abrió las puertas de la región
a vacunas de China. Poco después, Kirguistán
y Turkmenistán aprobaron la Sinopharm y Tayikistán
está a la espera de recibir sus Sinovac.
En Asia Central cada vez más todo gira entorno
a China.
Bueno, pero y todo esto, al final, ¿para
qué? ¿Por qué a China le interesa tanto
Asia Central? Y viceversa: ¿qué ganan los
istanes con el gigante asiático?
Atentos..
(LA LETRA PEQUEÑA)
Si sois seguidores asiduos de Visualpolitik,
no hace falta recordaros que la política
exterior china de hoy no tiene nada que ver
con lo que era hace cincuenta años. Es lo
que tiene ser un país con una economía mucho
más grande y próspera.
Bien, en lo que se refiere a Asia Central,
China empezó a ganar protagonismo en la década
de los 90.
(Recordad que hasta 1991 los istanes eran
parte de la Unión Soviética, y en esta última
etapa las relaciones chino-soviéticas dejaban
mucho que desear. Así que, a partir de esta
fecha, Pekín ha tenido que resolver los problemas
más triviales con sus nuevos vecinos: a ver
cómo delimitamos las fronteras, o qué hacemos
frente a la guerra civil en Tayikistán.
Pero el principal cambio se dio en los años
2000, cuando China se lanzó a invertir por
el mundo la enorme cantidad de dólares que
estaba acumulando gracias a su enorme superávit
comercial.)
Pero, y ¿por qué exactamente Asia Central?
Pues, fundamentalmente, por tres razones.
Fijaos.
(Por una parte, China comparte más de 3.000
kilómetros de frontera con Kazajistán, Kirguistán
y Tayikistán, y además tiene mucho en común
con los países de la región. Por ejemplo,
a comienzos de los 90, uno de cada mil habitantes
de China era kazajo, tayiko, uzbeko o kirguís.
Por otra parte, desde 1993 China consume más
energía de la que produce. Es decir, necesita
importarla. Así que los istanes se han convertido
para Pekín en una fuente crucial de petróleo
y gas.
Y, en tercer lugar, en 2013 China anunció
la creación de la Nueva Ruta de la Seda.
Por eso, Asia Central se convirtió en un
espacio clave de su parte terrestre, para
conectar los productos chinos con los mercados
europeos.)
Pero cómo creo que esto está más o menos
claro, pasemos si os parece a la siguiente
pregunta: ¿qué gana Asia Central en su relación
con China?
Pues, veréis, aquí hay que tener en cuenta
que, tras la caída de la URSS, los istanes
se convirtieron en los países más pobres
de todo el espacio postsoviético.
Durante décadas tuvieron unos sistemas de
producción muy interconectados entre sí,
y eran básicamente “economías de monocultivo”.
Es decir, muy especializadas en unos pocos
productos que producían a gran escala para
abastecer al resto de repúblicas. Pero luego
todo eso se vino abajo.
Claro que, ojalá todos los problemas de Asia
Central fueran económicos.
Pero no, porque salvo Kirguistán, en el plano
político son un ejemplo de no-democratización.
Hablamos de regímenes muy personalistas que
no tienen ningún interés por los derechos
humanos. Sumadle a eso la corrupción endémica,
y ya tenéis el retrato de una región en
la que pocos querrían invertir.
Por eso, los créditos de China fueron para
Asia Central como el maná caído del cielo.
Además, el dinero de Pekín no está condicionado
a reformas políticas ni nada por el estilo.
Y, además, al desarrollar gracias al dinero
chinos nuevas carreteras y gasoductos hacia
el este, los istanes están reduciendo su
dependencia histórica de Rusia.
Hasta aquí, podría parecer una relación
perfecta. Pero acordaos de que siempre hay
que leer la letra pequeña. Y es que, en sus
relaciones con Asia Central, China es la que
dicta las condiciones. Por eso, muchos contratos
implican el uso de maquinaria china, el empleo
de mano de obra china y la resolución de
posibles controversias ante tribunales chinos.
Y, por supuesto, hablamos de China, que no
es un país que juegue precisamente a ser
el más popular, empezando por las condiciones
laborales que suelen ser francamente malas.
Así que no penséis que está siendo coser
y cantar. En los dos últimos años ls región
ha visto más de cuarenta manifestaciones
en contra de la expansión china. Y en ocasiones
han tenido consecuencias directas.
(Un proyecto de 280 millones de dólares liderado
por China en Kirguistán es abandonado después
de las protestas)
En cualquier caso, con carácter general,
los sentimientos anti-chinos han crecido más
en Kazajistán y Kirguistán, países en los
que un tercio de la población tiene una opinión
negativa sobre el gigante asiático.
Por el contrario, China está mucho mejor
vista en los dos países con los que no hace
frontera: Uzbekistán y Turkmenistán.
Claro que en esta región del mundo la opinión
pública no representa ni mucho menos las
posturas oficiales.
Y si China tiene algo ganado, eso son los
corazones de las élites.
Daos cuenta de que la falta de transparencia
es una gran aliada de la corrupción: a menudo,
no hay forma de saber cuánto dinero se evapora
por el camino sin dejar rastro. En otras palabras,
que los enormes créditos de China les vienen
muy bien a los jerifaltes políticos de Asia
Central para cobrar su margen, su intermediación.
Y eso es una de las cosas que provoca que
muchas veces estos proyectos no tengan luego
el rendimiento esperado.
Y claro, ¿qué pasa cuando toca devolver
los préstamos?
(CHINA NO PERDONA LAS DEUDAS)
En economía, la deuda externa son todas las
obligaciones que un Estado tiene con otros
países o con instituciones extranjeras.
Por ejemplo, los créditos que ofrece el Eximbank
chino se traducen en deuda externa para los
países que reciben estos créditos. Ya os
podéis imaginar que ningún país de Asia
Central está exento de la deuda con China.
Pekín controla el 42% de la deuda externa
kirguisa, el 40% de la tayika, el 20% de la
uzbeka y el 10% de la kazaja. Sobre Turkmenistán
no os podemos ofrecer ningún dato porque
las estadísticas públicas no son el fuerte
de su régimen.
Lo que está claro es que los países más
endeudados son también los dos más pobres
de la región: Kirguistán y Tayikistán.
Y os preguntaréis: “¿por qué China le
presta tanto dinero a países que quizás
luego no puedan devolverlo?”.
Pues en el mundo de las relaciones internacionales
hay teorías para todo.
(Hace cuatro años, el académico Brahma Chellaney
presentó la suya, que se llama “la diplomacia
de la trampa de la deuda”. En resumen, viene
a decir que China no espera recuperar los
préstamos que ofrece a países poco desarrollados.
En vez de esto, pretende crear un vínculo
de dependencia política e incluso desafiar
la soberanía de estos Estados.)
Claro que esto es sólo una teoría. Desde
luego ni China es el diablo, ni Asia Central
ni ningún otro país del mundo están obligado
a aceptar sus créditos.
Aplicar sin más la teoría de la “diplomacia
de la trampa de la deuda” implicaría eximir
a las élites locales de toda responsabilidad.
Quizás el problema sea el incentivo perverso
que genera la corrupción: algo así como
“yo me llevo mi parte y ya veremos cómo
el estado paga luego la suya”.
El caso es que cada país está buscando sus
formas de hacer frente a la cada vez mayor
deuda china. Por ejemplo, Turkmenistán le
está vendiendo el gas por debajo del precio
del mercado. Kazajistán, que hace frontera
con la región china de Xinxiang, está manteniendo
un perfil bajo frente a la persecución de
los uigures.
Pero quizás los casos más interesantes son
los de Tajikistán y Kirguistán. Para estos
dos países, una de las formas más habituales
de devolver la deuda a China es cediendo los
derechos de explotación de recursos naturales.
Por eso, podemos encontrarnos noticias como
esta:
(Tayikistán ratifica la transferencia de
minas de oro a China)
A día de hoy, hasta un 80% de las minas de
oro de Tayikistán están bajo el control
de empresas chinas.
Pero no solo eso. Porque hay rumores de que
la reticencia de Tayikistán a entrar en la
Unión Económica Euroasiática, de la que
ya os hablamos en un vídeo que os dejo en
la descripción, se explica precisamente por
los intereses de Pekín.
Y la guinda en el pastel: En el año 2011,
el Parlamento tayiko ratificó un nuevo protocolo
sobre la delimitación de las fronteras, por
el que China recibía más de mil kilómetros
cuadrados en el sistema montañoso de Pamir.
Es decir, casi un 1% de todo el territorio
de Tayikistán. China no perdona sus deudas.
(La situación de Kirguistán es aún peor.
Al igual que el resto de los países de Asia
Central, su economía depende fuertemente
de las remesas, que suponen más del 30% del
PIB.
Por eso la pandemia de coronavirus supuso
un golpe durísimo para este país. Y ahora
lo tiene todavía más difícil para solventar
su deuda con China, que también supone en
torno a un 30% de su PIB. )
Seguro, seguro que no vais a acertar cuál
fue la propuesta oficial para hacer frente
a esta deuda. ¿Preparados? Aquí la tenéis:
Se abre una cuenta para la transferencia de
fondos para pagar la deuda externa en Kirguistán)
Habéis oído bien: el Ministerio de Finanzas
kirguís ha abierto una cuenta bancaria para
que cualquier persona pueda sufragar la deuda
externa del país. Y lo más fuerte es que
no es la primera vez que pasa. En 2007, el
entonces presidente Atambáyev también abrió
una cuenta bancaria igual. Entonces, la deuda
externa era de 1.991.000.000 dólares.
Ahora, bien ¿cuánto dinero creéis que recibió?
Evidentemente poco: ni más ni menos que 3.350
dólares. En 2020 les ha ido un poco mejor:
12.000 dólares, que por otra parte no es
nada en comparación con la deuda externa
de Kirguistán. De momento, el país no tiene
más remedio que seguir ahondando su dependencia
de China.
Y ahora, la pregunta es para vosotros: ¿qué
os parece esta idea de crowdfunding? ¿conocíais
el papel de China en Asia Central? ¿se puede
aprovechar los créditos de China sin caer
en la dependencia? Podéis dejar vuestras
respuestas en los comentarios.